Saturday Night Live alum five-time Emmy
Award winner for his tremendous Dennis
Miller live show also a couple years in
the booth of Monday Night Football his
his new special on comedy dynamics fake
news real jokes is available on Amazon I
to steam Google Play and several other
platforms you can check on his adorable
deplorable tour dates in a short moment
we will get to that but right now I turn
and find Dennis Miller here in the front
nice to be here with you think we're
shooting out at the end of the tarmac
that they had the final scene in Michael
Mann's magnum opus heat Tom Sizemore is
the best line in there where DeNiro
explains to him how tough the next gig
is gonna be you go home you don't want
this you've got a family does that hold
in their own thing and sighs what takes
that long beaten he looks up at me hey
for me the action is the juice it's like
by the way congrats on that Halloween
costume very very few dads will go out
as a broad sort of addy Andros the Great
Pumpkin how's it go I'm groovy man this
is a nice scene that's nice kids here
and I just saw your picture your real
kid you know the boy who was that's what
it was they turn into Harry Potter they
I know thanks man I appreciate that so
are you you're watching a little bit
more football these days you know here's
here you should admit when you didn't
see something some football is always
gonna be a violent game but it just is a
neurosis about that bothers me when
trying to make it the completely safe
violent game this seems like a fool's
errand if a young man has worked his
whole life to get bulked up and loves
the rock other people's worlds for
millions of dollars an unlimited women I
don't
calm the 65 year old guy used to do the
news I've got some thoughts on your life
just right I'd like to let them do its
thing but I have noticed now that guys
you know I grew up watching branch
tingling you know all that stuff that
right people aren't launching anymore
and I've seen some entirely what you go
to football for which is quite a hits
breastplate got with and I thought all
right I guess it's a hard drive thing
where you dowel that down and then a few
years later it's the new norm that's
always been the conversation at least
from the management of the NFL is that
the players will adjust the only problem
is is it's always on the defender to
know where the the guy is gonna hit the
captain Crouch position the crash
position it sometimes it's on them not a
perfect system but I must say for the
first time I think I always expect
people to concede when they've missed
the point I think I missed the point a
little I do think that it can happen
immediately and that zone between
writing it right are getting it the old
way I sometimes get impetuous and cranky
I'm a bit of an old get off my lawn guy
but now that I've seen it a few years I
start to see the wisdom of just people
not thinking about going high at all
knowing they have to go into the bread
basket right the stuff that's happened
to Clay Matthews is still maddening I
mean just got that earlier on this
season well I think they sent out a
directive see that's the thing now
everybody's taping everybody else I
don't know how they get it out now but I
assume it's like Al Davis locusts on
trash they have to find somebody
mentalize they hit it's like yeah GD
spradlin looking at Martin she did say I
want him to be dispatched with extreme
prejudice
exactly so I think the NFL they can't
come right out and say listen we've
gotta loosen that rule up a little word
we're being too mighty but there's no
doubt a phone call was yeah something
something in-house where they go this is
we're taking away from what our people
watch our thing for absolutely what
Matthews did if you watch Matthews if
he's eventually put into the Hall of
Fame or the 100 greatest players of a
deck
they'll show clips that are now
penalties it's like iwachniuk night
train lane ninth rated player I think on
the NFL Network of all time and I look
at me go night Ringling couldn't play
now they like every week I'd watch him
being in the you know the fine protocol
or whatever and back then though you
look at Bednarik splat Lambert I mean
it's just it's listen took me a lot of
get used to it it's the new game it's
allowed me to watch more I don't get all
of it but I do get more of it Dennis
Miller here on the Rich Eisen show did
you meet al Davis when you were doing
Monday night across for the my name is
Laura wondering yeah listen you don't I
didn't meet Rickles to have him be a
lovefest you know you want him to tear
you new ones you're now to be
indifferent to you so Davis and all of a
sudden he comes out and he's a sandy
Duncan you know he could care about you
sitting there in a Kevlar suit like Tony
Robertson Annie Hall you know putting
the visor down I don't know what the
whole deals about I do know this when
you're when you're turning on a cat like
Marcus Allen you've lost your gourd a
little I mean Marcus Allen was the
quintessential gamer right nobody more
clever at the end nobody picking up a
blitzing backer nobody a run catch
specialist and nobody more of a raid it
right when out Davis turned on him I
thought brother that's getting that's
like one of those guys who you can tell
defines himself through the wake in his
you know the flotsam and jetsam in his
wake right Marcus Allen was a man and a
great player for that organization for
him to sit him for a couple years it
broke my heart so when you were doing a
Monday night football two years who
impressed you most that you met do you
think ingenious how Michaels is I got a
great story you have to believe it like
you did that joke well we are live but
if you could I'll do the bleep that and
I'll sleep instead of the work I want to
put anybody over the brink here most
indelicate society they're gonna dive
off a cliff alright so everything else
is absolutely crazy I would love to do a
show where you could do everything else
is nuts except the language okay so
we're in the booth somebody gets their
ankle hurt they're wrapping it in gauze
bandages and I was a genius he's like
that cat on the Sullivan Show spending
the play
started at the pusher he's kicking it to
the debut on the network and then he
takes it over to the owner story he's
got salary cap he calls the play frozen
to foxy for the telestrator throw it to
me for the weird rejoined to regather it
for the next hike and I'm sitting there
guy guy's a genius but the only thing is
out you could make him laugh and then
he'd get thrown off he couldn't gather
himself and my arcane references really
many months I remember when they were
watching this getting this guy's getting
his ankle wrapped and I say towel on the
air I say you know me no and I used to
call him Venus and they made me stop
because they thought I was saying penis
and I you know I just said Venus don't
feel you note from taglio boo or
something are you calling him penis yeah
that's what I'm doing and calling how
Michael penis but it's like it come
being us anymore psycho Beano and then
there's let's afford medication for
God's sake leave me alone so I go you
know al I haven't seen that much fabric
used since the environmental artist
Christo wrapped the Pont Neuf bridge in
Paris and I hits this these button which
cuts his voice out to the home viewer
what the blank actually olmeyer say no
well Christo environmental artists all
reference 36 boys been to an I was that
they rest in peace don omar I was at an
art gallery wearing all of his art was
in the world I was in the room so he he
gave the tough jarhead back I bet I know
that he was funny in the room I mean
[ __ ] like behind closed doors and just
toss smoke have ass Mick some Skippy
crunchy a Pepsi you know you'd be
thinking this guy is and the thing with
Al too is that you know they now have
in the booth with NBC or part of their
broadcast Terry McCauley former NFL ref
to give a explanation as to why that's
right well I'm saying is that is that is
that that that's how knows the rulebook
perhaps better than most
refs that's why he's as great as he is
as he can call as you say they he's got
all those dishes in the area can I mean
women about during the end of the game
because Chris Collins or who seems like
a sweet guy and he's obviously great
announcer not being okay but he was
saying it's time I think Jason Garrett
if he was fired or his phone would be
ringing off the hook you know doing the
st. Chris thing and now goes really do
you think that good for you well I
wouldn't trust her who were you talking
about it I wouldn't trust oh no it was
not Jason Garrett was the guy who took
the job would be offered the Garrett
thing right there Alison really you
think so I was bridling say good for you
I wouldn't trust Josh McDaniels with my
place in line at Epcot laterz I just
told our spotter too that he's laughing
his stereo man fantastic
so the comedy dynamics comedy special
Dennis Miller fake news real jokes you
shot it in Tennessee Knoxville Knoxville
Tennessee yeah I knew that was booked
right now I I work better in Middle
America now I find it's less strident
than the coast where enjoy the dude
enjoy the live audience do you like the
web audience stuff Dennis left to my own
devices I'm you know I'm John Hurt in
that movie where he never touched his
foot on ground he just cruises rod
you've ever let in great science-fiction
movie where as a plane he lives it
that's what I said if I want to go and
tell my jokes you got to go out and you
know he'd be Johnny Appleseed right go
so yeah I kind of like it but I'm not I
I don't have these stories like when I
was in puberty I did hellzapoppin in the
family right
I'm a natural at it right okay and then
you're going on the adorable deplorable
tour mark style you know that cat I do
not know brilliant okay google him he's
a political commentator but he's also a
great raconteur a funny guy we're gonna
go out and try to do a few evenings
together of Q&A a little recon thing but
super smart cop okay in February you'll
be in Reading PA in Syracuse New York
Rochester New York wilkes-barre PA in
the early March right there it's our
Rust Belt tour that's your Rust Belt
tour going out there and doing all the
Marv levy
then yes so I've got Michael Douglas on
the show tomorrow yeah do you got a good
story yeah and a great the best actor
everything I ever did or the best acting
note I ever got okay
I'm doing disclosure and I've been in a
few films but they this was Barry
Levinson Donald subtle and Michael
Douglas Michaels so cool I go out and
we're doing our first scene I'm just
meeting Michael I said listen I do do
you think when you act do you what do
you think odd it's like I'm doing it
that way and he said don't get screwed
up with that he's in this movies or what
we're friends right office friends he
said make me laugh and get to the
pertinent information but just think
make me laugh such a great note because
then I thought okay just vibe with a guy
try to make him laugh like you would in
an office situation with a work mate and
then tag on the information I was
thinking about how do I deliver this
information and it's all about
misdirecting yourself it's better when
you're not looking at what you're doing
I can see that self-consciousness is the
ruination of good acting and that was a
good note for Michael and no kidding so
so did you ad-lib some of those lines
over you saying I ad libbed all the
stuff leading up to sort of the the
pertinent part but before that it would
be me looking at him as he has confessed
earlier that he him to me more I've had
an office affair and you know just
saying instead of saying you know her
saying really you're hitting that you
know anyway and then that makes him
laugh because that's unexpected run you
can deliver the next part of it but I
would say that's the best lesson I've
ever had about acting is pay less
attention to the
you cannot be self-conscious about it
right he's the least self-conscious cat
I know I'm telling you he I've seen him
in things I remember we were eating one
night in a Mediterranean restaurant do
you know how the lady comes up to belly
dancer she wants to damn you to dance
with her and I'm completely frozen up I
turn into the town elders from Footloose
I can't even think about it Gordon Gekko
Bam Bam I'm playin that's he's just an
easygoing cat who happens to be world
famous and he's not effective yeah I'm
excited to have him here tomorrow so are
you watching tonight's game you're gonna
say you will you'll be you'll be settled
in watching yeah I think I will this is
a good one you know I come from
Pittsburgh and we've got Cam Newton is
in his groove and he's starting to grow
a Manning yep I didn't get some of it
early I'm starting to see that whether
you like it or not you don't quite get
the next generation like you should as
you get older I always fancied myself as
a reasonably and I read a lot I try to
stay in touch but I'm becoming the
cranky guy like I was watching the other
day with my son I love my son dearly and
I think he's one of the wisest men I've
ever met and the guy pulled the thing up
anyone for the phone it's a whole new
world he's doing an homage to Joe horn
yes man I thought that's right he did
that years ago and he says he's got a
flip phone I didn't even notice that I
just went to the right and I thought man
it happens and you're not even aware of
it that you have to say this is not your
ear right right this is a new era and
that is not as big big a you know
misstep as you think it is well I had
the similar reaction and I knew he was
paying homage to Joe horn at that point
in time because you're taking on a Rams
team you're giving him half a field down
two scores with four minutes to go with
two timeouts in the two-minute warning
left that's exactly what I thought but
then I had one of their players one of
his teammates Cameron Jordan from the
defensive line one of the best pass
rushes in the league I had him on two
days ago and he said that the team loved
it team
loved it nobody was sitting there saying
what like the coach Sean Payton kind of
barked at him a little bit well you know
there's no tectonic seismic shift in the
rubric of the culture when you can look
me straight in the face with no irony
and say I knew it was a joke or no no I
know but it's true though this is Joe
you can now do to social media you can
go through the entire movie a star is
born in one day you could put up a tweet
at 8 a.m. you can become famous off it
by 10 you could be tried by it by noon
you can hire a publicist of dust to get
you out of it and you can supplicate
yourself and grovel it at 9 that you're
back on the 18 what does it mean then
that it's my job to know that it's a Joe
horn wash that I'm doing my job
appropriately where where's John's
brother you could be out here moving
these orange cones around right here in
the on the the offset of heat check out
fake news reel jokes right now on the
comedy dynamics platformer it's on
Amazon iTunes steam the Google Play and
several other platforms at Dennis DMZ on
Twitter to find out more information
good to see you sir
I'm so happy for you you wanted the most
decent man I've met nice I know you've
got your wife yeah it's a major chord
babe next parent you deserve it you're
in good cat Thank You Dennis I
appreciate you saying that at Dennis DMZ
on Twitter again we'll set up the rest
of the book tomorrow show big show
tomorrow and take on some more phone
calls before we close up shop the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience